♪ ♪
>> IMPRACTICAL.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES PARDONING HIMSELF
WOULD JUST BE UNTHINKABLE.
AND IT WOULD LEAD TO PROBABLY AN
IMMEDIATE IMPEACHMENT.
HOUSE, SENATE WILL BE UNDER
TREMENDOUS PRESSURE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NO NEED TO
DO THAT.
HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG.
>> THANKFULLY THE PRESIDENT
HASN'T DONE ANYTHING WRONG AND
WOULDN'T HAVE NEED FOR A PARDON.
>> Shannon: MATT SCHLAPP, WITH
"THE HILL."
A.B. STODDARD, GUY BENSON.
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TWEETED A LOT,
AS HE ALWAYS DOES.
HE SAYS LISTEN I'VE BEEN TOLD BY
NUMEROUS LEGAL SCHOLARS I HAVE
THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO PARDON
MYSELF BUT WHY WOULD I DO THAT
WHEN I HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG?
>> THIS IS BASICALLY WHAT THEY
CALLED A POLITICAL QUESTION.
YOU ARE THE LAWYER.
I AM NOT.
THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD BE IN A
PLACE WHERE THE PRESIDENT WOULD
BE PARDONING HIMSELF, MAYBE IT
GOES TO THE NATION'S HIGHEST
COURT, I THINK WITH THE
PRESIDENT IS REALLY TRYING TO
SAY IS THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THIS WHOLE CONTROVERSY,
INCLUDING SPYING ON THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, SPYING ON
MEMBERS OF THE OPPOSING
CAMPAIGN.
LOTS OF QUESTIONS.
HE IS SAYING I'M GOING TO FIGHT
FIRE WITH FIRE.
YOU ARE DOING THINGS I VIEW
EXTRA CONSTITUTIONAL, INCLUDING
A SPECIAL COUNSEL ACTING MORE
LIKE I SAID AND CONFIRMED ACTOR.
HE SAYS I'M GOING TO FIGHT IT.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO PLAY A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT ED MARKEY HAD
TO SAY ABOUT THIS.
HERE'S HIS TAKE.
>> IT'S NOT A RULE OF TRUMP.
IT'S A RULE OF LAW THAT WE LIVE
UNDER THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
EVEN IN 1974, RICHARD NIXON'S
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MADE IT QUITE
CLEAR THAT NIXON COULD NOT
PARDON HIMSELF.
THE SAME THING IS TRUE HERE.
>> Shannon: HE IS REFERRING TO
A MEMO WRITTEN BY ACTING
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
SET UNDER THE FUNDAMENTAL ROLE
THAT NO ONE CAN BE A JUDGE IN
HIS OWN CASE, THE PRESIDENT
CANNOT PARDON HIMSELF.
1974.
>> NIXON HOPED IT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE, BUT IT WASN'T.
THIS IS, REMEMBER WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF SPIN WIRE, A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN THAT RUDY GIULIANI IS
WAGING IN THE PRESS ON BEHALF OF
DONALD TRUMP AT HIS REQUEST TO
SPIN THINGS A CERTAIN WAY SO AS
TO FORM THE OPINIONS AMONG TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AND OTHERS AND
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS WERE
SUPINE AND COMPLETELY
ACQUIESCENT AT THIS POINT.
>> Shannon: THEY DISAGREE ON
SOME OF THESE POINTS.
>> I DON'T HEAR ANYONE TODAY
FIGHTING THAT PARDON THING.
TED CRUZ WENT SILENT FOR 18
SECONDS WHEN ASKED IF IT WAS
CONSTITUTIONAL FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO FIRE HIMSELF.
HE BOASTED, TO PARDON HIMSELF.
I'M SORRY.
THEY DO NOT PUSH BACK.
THEY SAID IF THAT WAS MY LAWYER,
I WOULD GET A NEW ONE.
>> Shannon: SOUNDS LIKE A PUSH
BACK.
>> WE ARE TAKING AN OATH TO THE
CONSTITUTION OR NOT THE MAN.
HE'S NOT ALLOWED TO DO THIS.
THEY ARE NEARLY DICTATORIAL
POWERS HE IS DESCRIBING IN THE
20 PAGE MEMO AND THEN THE TWEETS
THIS MORNING.
IT'S OUT OF LINE.
NO ONE PUSHED BACK THAT HARD.
THEY CALLED IT A DISTRACTION.
BOB CORKER WONDERED WHY HE TALKS
THIS WAY.
TAKES AWAY THE SUBJECTS OF THE
DAY.
SHANNON, LET'S GET BACK TO THE
FACT THAT THE TRUMP TEAM
COMPLETELY LIED ABOUT THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING, DESCRIPTION
THAT THE PRESIDENT GAVE MONEY
DICTATED A FULL STATEMENT.
THEY KNOW BOB MUELLER HAS NOT.
THEY KNOW THAT THE MAN ON THE
LEGAL TEAM LEFT BECAUSE HE
BELIEVED A COVER-UP WAS IN THE
HATCHING.
>> Shannon: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS.
LET'S BREAK IT DOWN.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
RUDY GIULIANI SAID ABOUT WHY HE
DOESN'T WANT THE PRESIDENT TO
TESTIFY BECAUSE HE SAID IF YOU
REMEMBER THINGS DIFFERENTLY, IF
THE ACCOUNTS CHANGE, IT CREATES
A LOT OF PROBLEMS EVEN IF THERE
IS INNOCENT EXPLANATION FOR
EVERYTHING ABOUT WHO DICTATED
THE LETTER, WHAT INPUT THE
PRESIDENT HAD.
SEEMS THE STORY IS CHANGE.
GIULIANI SAID NO.
BUT THIS IS WHY I DON'T WANT HIM
INTERVIEWING THE PRESIDENT.
>> IT HURTS THEIR CREDIBILITY,
NO QUESTION.
AS I LOOK BACK AND I LOOK AT
THESE CLIPS AND I WATCH THEM
FROM THE SUNDAY SHOWS, I AM
THINKING WHAT ON EARTH ARE WE
DOING HERE.
WHY ARE WE LISTENING TO THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM SPECULATE
IN REAL TIME ABOUT WHETHER HE
MIGHT DO SOMETHING THAT THEY
HASTEN TO ADD HE WILL NEVER HAVE
TO DO IT.
TO ME IT'S AN OBVIOUS, IT'S A
CRAZY HYPOTHETICAL.
HE WOULD NEVER COME TO THAT.
NEXT QUESTION, NO COMMENT.
INSTEAD, TRUMP DOUBLES DOWN AND
SAYS YOU BET I CAN DO IT WHICH
IS WHY WE ALSO DO HERE DEBATING
THE FINER POINTS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THE PRESIDENT COULD
HYPOTHETICALLY GET TO THAT
POINT.
>> Shannon: AGAIN, HE SAYS
THERE'S NO NEED FOR IT.
HE WANTS TO BE ON THE RECORD
SAYING I BELIEVE BECAUSE OF WHAT
LEGAL SCHOLARS HAVE TOLD ME I
WOULD BE RIGHT TO DO THIS.
>> THERE IS A QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE PRESIDENT LIMITS OF
THE PARDON POWER BUT THERE'S
ALSO A QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER A
PRESIDENT CAN BE INDICTED.
I THINK WHAT THE FOUNDERS AND
THE WRITERS OF THE CONSTITUTION
ENVISIONED IS THAT A POLITICIAN
THE HEAD OF OUR GOVERNMENT,
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
CHIEF EXECUTIVE, THE BEST WAY TO
HANDLE THESE QUESTIONS IS THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS THROUGH THE
HOUSE WITH CONVICTION AND THE
SENATE.
THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
THE PRESIDENT COULD BE INDICTED,
IT HINGES ON THIS QUESTION OF
PARDONS AND HINGES ON THE
QUESTION, IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
WE HAVE BOB MUELLER ACTING MUCH
MORE LIKE A SENATE-CONFIRMED
OFFICER OF THE CONSTITUTION AND
NOT LIKE SOMEBODY WHO WAS PICKED
TO DO A DISCRETE TASK.
THAT'S THE REAL QUESTION.
IS BOB MUELLER BEING MANAGED?
IS HE ABLE TO PULL PEOPLE ON HIS
TEAM AT HIS DISCRETION?
IF THAT'S THE CASE, HE SHOULD BE
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE.
IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS.
DICTATORIAL WHICH YOU KNOW IS
GOING TO UPSET PEOPLE.
>> I SAID NEARLY DICTATORIAL.
>> Shannon: IF THERE ARE
ENOUGH PEOPLE CONVINCE THIS
PERSON IS OUT OF LINE WITH HER
HAS COMMITTED A CRIME OR NOT OR
PARDON HIMSELF OR NOT, THEY
STILL HAVE A MEANS.
HE IS NOT LIMITLESS IN HIS
POWER.
THERE STILL A WAY TO REIN HIM IN
IF THE LAWMAKERS ARE CONVINCED.
SPEAK UP BETWEEN THE MEMO AND
HIS TWEETS COME HE'S BASICALLY
SAYING I CAN TERMINATE THIS AT
ANY TIME.
I CAN'T BE INDICTED.
I CAN PARDON MYSELF.
HE USED THE WORDS "ABSOLUTE
RIGHT."
HE'S PRESENTING HIMSELF AS ABOVE
THE INVESTIGATION LET ALONE THE
LAWS.
THEY ARE PREPARING WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS FOR MONTHS NOW,
RUDY GIULIANI IS PREPARING A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN IN ORDER TO,
BASICALLY SAYING HE CAN'T BE
INDICTED, HE CAN ONLY BE
IMPEACHED.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH, THE
REASON I RAISED A TRUMP TOWER
MEETING IN THE STATEMENT ABOUT
IT IS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
MUELLER PERCEIVES IT TO BE AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
IS LIKELY TO BE PRESENTED THAT
WAY.
THE LETTER FROM JANUARY WITH
THOSE ASSERTIONS IS DESIGNED TO
SAY BUT YOU CAN'T EVEN REALLY
ASSESS IT AS OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE BECAUSE HE CAN'T
OBSTRUCT THE LAW.
SO HE IS SAYING TO CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS YOU CAN'T EVEN
IMPEACH HIM FOR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> Shannon: IT'S NOT LIKE
YESTERDAY THAT PEOPLE DECIDED
THERE HAD TO BE A P.R. COMPONENT
OF THE POLITICAL FIGHTS THEY ARE
WAGING HERE.
THAT IS AS OLD AS TIME.
>> CORRECT.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ALL SORT OF ANALYZING AND
GRANULAR DETAIL THE CONTENTS OF
THE LETTER, THE 20 PAGE LETTER
THAT WENT OUT IN JANUARY, ALMOST
THE ENTIRE LEGAL TEAM IS GONE
NOW.
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT SOME OF THE
ASSERTIONS THEY MADE IN THERE,
THEY ARE OBSOLETE WHICH IS WHY I
AM BAFFLED WHY RUDY AND OTHERS
WOULD EVEN INDULGE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT SELF PARDONS.
THAT'S A DISTRACTION RIGHT NOW.
IT'S GETTING WAY AHEAD OF
ANYTHING, AND YET THEY SORT OF
THREW THAT CHUM IN THE WATER
COME OR AT LEAST RESPONDED TO
THE BAIT FROM THE PRESS.
MEN TRUMP DOUBLE DOWN.
I DON'T THINK THAT DOES HIM MUCH
OF A SERVICE.
>> Shannon: WE WILL SEE.
THERE IS AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT DUE OUT.
WE HAVE THE MUELLER